hey guys this is vadim and welcome to
max tech it's been three months since we
got our hands on the 2018 macbook air
and our thoughts have completely changed
about it at first we were disappointed
with a few key problems with the new
MacBook Air and we even recommended the
2017 MacBook Pro instead after three
months we've realized that the air is
actually the best choice for almost
everyone I'll explain why in just a
minute before the new MacBook Air was
released thousands of people were still
using the old MacBook Air with its
extremely outdated design low-quality
display in old tech those people just
wanted a relatively cheap and reliable
Apple laptop for everyday tasks and it
did just that now we've got a brand new
upgraded MacBook Air that's up to date
with the latest technology it's not
perfect but it's world's better than the
old one as a video editor there were a
few things the new MacBook Air lack that
were really disappointing especially the
display even though it's packin a
high-resolution retina display the
screen itself just doesn't get very
bright and it's not nearly as color
accurate as other MacBooks like the 2017
MacBook Pro that's my biggest problem
with it but I've realized that it
doesn't really matter for most people
who don't do photo or video editing and
the display brightness is fine for
almost everyone at least until you try
to take it outside on a bright day the
second biggest problem I had with it is
the dual-core processor most of the
laptop market has already moved on to
quad-core processors so it's a little
disappointing to see that the air hasn't
however after using it for three months
I've realized that it runs basically
everything you need on a daily basis
pretty well many old MacBook Air users
were completely fine with the speed of
the old dual-core processor and the new
ones even faster something that really
mattered on the old MacBook Air was the
port's it was loaded with tons of them
and the new one is limited to just two
it kind of sucks but you can get a USB
hub on Amazon for relatively cheap to
fix that problem the last thing I want
to complain about is the price it's
eleven hundred ninety nine dollars two
hundred dollars more than the old
MacBook Air making it a bit more
difficult for many people to obtain
however three months later you can
easily find a brand new 2018 MacBook Air
for less than eleven hundred dollars in
fact it's currently on sale on Amazon
for ten seventy nine I linked that sale
in the video description below so you
can check it out in reality the
difference in
is well worth it for everything you're
getting now let's talk about what makes
the 2018 MacBook Air so special and what
makes me think is the best choice for
most people out there first of all the
battery life is amazing apple says it
lasts two hours longer than any other
current gen MacBook and trust me they're
not lying it seems to last forever the
updated design really makes it look like
a modern Mac especially now that the
huge silver display bezels are gone the
trackpad is now much larger and more
comfortable to use and it's now using
force touch tech so it doesn't actually
click the motor beneath it vibrates to
simulate a click this means that you get
an even clicking feel even at the
corners of the trackpad some users don't
really like the Loki travel of the new
MacBook Airs keyboard but I personally
don't mind it it was pretty easy to get
used to it also comes with a touch ID
sensor in the corner for logging in and
buying stuff online using Apple pay
which I don't really care for it but it
is convenient to have one huge
difference you're going to notice is the
speakers they sound so much better than
the old MacBook Air the old model
actually doesn't pack any speaker
grilles the sound just comes from under
the keyboard and it doesn't sound good
compared to the new speakers just listen
for yourself what's great about the new
MacBook Air is that it comes with a t2
security chip which enhances security
encrypt storage on the fly and takes
care of a bunch of different controllers
so the processor doesn't have to I
personally believe that in about six
years Apple will release a new Mac OS
software update that will require the t2
chip basically putting an end to the
hackintosh so if you're wanting to keep
your MacBook for a long time this is a
huge reason to buy the new MacBook Air
finally even though it only has two
ports there Thunderbolt 3 ports so they
can deliver 40 gigabits per second of
throughput to connect everything from
external storage external GPUs for
gaming and video editing and even
connect a 5k display the new MacBook Air
basically offers everything the average
user would need and more from battery
life and reliability to speaker and
display quality it's got you covered
thanks to the H n processors modern
technology you can even do casual photo
or video editing it may take a bit
longer than other Mac's but it'll get
the job
now if you're more serious about your
professional work like requiring a
highly color accurate display you should
look to the MacBook Pro instead and if
you're doing a lot of graphics intensive
work like video editing investing a
little bit more cash into the 2018 15
inch MacBook Pro is a wise choice it'll
easily pay for itself in time savings
overall the 2018 MacBook Air is the Mac
that almost everybody should be buying
in 2019 I'm extremely satisfied with it
after using it for three months and I
truly believe that you will - this has
been vadim with max sack thanks for
watching and make sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on more videos like
this one